and we're back with our questions from
the Internet's well this is an obvious
one but I think it's a good one we
should ask this on this day why do you
think Americans are still so obsessed
with royalty
yeah why I put it to you
why to insert a fact here but the last
poll I saw sort of some like six percent
of Americans were fascinating I think
the media that's everybody I know that's
what they told the pollster you know how
they said I was here when when when the
last royal wedding happened wasn't
anything like that now come on we've
been living under a rock the last month
it's it's everywhere it's everywhere in
the media do you think it's really what
do you think the media - right because
the media only covers what's important
they never pander to what people want
watch yeah I want so it can't be that
people real Laura come on you know I
watched it on the PI want Camilla to be
king hi Lisa he has Dijon water look
underneath huh well I bet she's hot
though yeah she is he looks pretty happy
with her and I think he did let me tell
you boy the heart wants what it wants
I'm telling you know everybody has a
type I know I mean who would have
Algeron to philia
the attraction to older people ugly word
for a lovely thought how weird that you
of all people would know about that just
in the seemed like a John Waters area um
but you know it's one thing to be a wet
blanket about you know I'm glad you
brought that up about unemployment but
come on people do care about this
wedding they're talking about it
endlessly if you look at the ratings it
was everywhere it's fantasy people are
tired of reality that's there you go
thank you that's fantasy well then how
about we replace a real life do our own
version I mean I think we should just
accept it that we have our own royalty
that called corporations and when they
merge we could have a wedding throw
money why not
everything oh oh we're logos happy fun
everything's political but it was a
reality show where we didn't look down
on them maybe that was it it didn't ask
you to feel superior to all the people
on it which is maybe that's what it were
I know I think you need to apologize for
the audience for making everything such
a downer and political know what do you
think folks do I need to apologize
nobody needs to apologize about happy he
was just joking
okay other are any of you worried about
your iPhone tracking your whereabouts is
privacy a thing of the past uh yes I
think I think it's a thing of the past
yeah and I don't think people care
nobody cares no you know I think when
we're spread you know sharing almost
intimacy right us exactly we haven't got
a lot of know they want it I'm pretty
unblocked vailable and yet you said well
I was gonna read this quote on the air
let me read it on overtime this is one
of the reviews on your book from the
Washington Post waters is a greater
national treasure than 90% of the people
who are given Kennedy Center Honors
although Palin December and happy happy
not safe TV the headlight the Kennedys
Oh
the best thing that ever happened we're
gonna see it it's gonna happen you think
it could happen yeah under President
Trump they're not the only time I was
ever in the white invited to the White
House was for Regan with Ronnie Atwater
who was my fan uh yeah and he knew
everything about exploitation movies and
we went there and all he did was talk
about the bloody pit of horror and every
horror movie and showed me Nixon's
bathroom it said that's where the button
was if he's on the toilet at the end of
the world he pushes and he said Nancy's
not here come on it was like being over
someone's house when they were
babysitting well I think you just
guaranteed you will never receive a
Kennedy say uh should a photo ID be
required in order to vote as several
state legislatures are proposing no no
well nothing so I think that it should
be as easy as possible for anybody I
know to be trust me right I voted twice
before I think you license that once
really in one of them yeah how'd you get
away with easy and it was before picture
ID ruined everything because I used to
just ask if you're gonna vote and they
said no and I said can I use your card
and I voted for shirley Chisholm a
couple times I loved her afraid you're
playing right into our product our
problem is I'm sorry I'm just telling
you I believe if you believe strong
enough go out and vote as much as you
can oh yeah
yeah there's no motivation for that well
alright our problem is not people voting
not enough here right I mean that's
right we make up for apathy um is there
a problem with just getting a voting
card in the mail or something I don't I
get it
maybe with an iPhone that's all you need
you don't need any kind of look you know
photo ID why first of all why can't we
do it on the weekend yeah that's a much
more weak you know voting ID to mail and
I open up voting for a week or two a
week you know this is what most other
countries mail they did all right now
some can't you vote a we can help yeah
yes you can yeah but of course you know
that most we have to do it on Tuesdays
cuz people are farming right I'm gonna
be my breasts so unsexy when they vote
did you ever notice people people look
terrible when they vote on did you ever
will see those film crews when you vote
like try to pick up somebody when you're
both alright we gotta go
thank you folks
you